let's jump into that first store we got
this one from the Daily Mail quote they
tell us to be peaceful Trump issues
another threat and tells Soros backed
animal Alvin Bragg to drop the Stormy
Daniels case as grand jury is canceled
for the rest of the week and questions
grow about looming indictment Manhattan
grand jury members were told not to show
up to court on Thursday sources tell
dailymail.com prosecutors are having
trouble convincing the jury to indict
Trump over hush money payments to Stormy
Daniels Trump is expected to fly to Waco
Texas on Saturday for a campaign event
Trump's also raised 1.5 million dollars
off of it I think he's done absolutely
the right thing I think he's doing the
right thing by continually calling this
out and I think only because he called
it out are they backing down
so they don't convene the grand juries
on Friday that's what I've seen reported
which means not Monday not Tuesday not
Wednesday not Thursday every single step
of the way it's been kicked back and now
we don't even know if it's going to
happen so how does so they get a chance
they want to convince the jury but if
they can't convince the jury I think
that means that they lose the case I
don't think that means you get to keep
trying to convince them every day but is
there some legal precedent where you're
allowed to be like you don't believe me
yet all right we'll see you again
tomorrow until they break the jury and
make the jury go the way they want them
to grand juries are not prosecutions all
they're doing is trying to get an
indictment so it's a preponderance of
evidence hey here's a picture of a guy
near a crime scene he may have done it
we've got a bunch of evidence we want to
bring it to trial okay indict him and
the jury's like no that's not enough
evidence they're like okay well we'll
come back tomorrow and see if you change
your mind and if you don't change your
mind we're going to bring you back every
day until you maybe change your mind
like what is this what kind of duress is
that to put a jury under if they don't
want to do it they don't want to do it
yes
I think there's exculpatory evidence
that outright proves Donald Trump didn't
do it and they're desperately trying to
do this anyway but I think that Donald
Trump calling this out and saying
they're trying to arrest me is what
caused this to basically start breaking
apart
high level of media scrutiny political
scrutiny
Alvin Bragg is probably sweating it he
should have let her send it to to
Congress I have a feeling that come next
week it probably won't happen not to
mention I'm willing to bet when
Democrats saw the news that Trump raised
1.5 million dollars in three days they
were like dude you got to stop doing
this yeah like I know it's good for your
career and all but you're you're feeling
is his War chest I think he I think this
guy learned what every Republican
primary opponent of trump learned the
hard way in 2016 which is this this is
what Trump is good at this is
um feeding the narrative like Trump is
the headline all week long and and he's
both playing the victim and kicking this
guy's ass at the same time and raising a
bunch of money and and I think the the
call came down from somebody and said
you're helping this guy and you're
getting killed you better stop
so it's it's politics it's not a legal
thing at all it's about it's about the
narrative that they wanted to create and
this is what Trump is a master at that's
why I think he came out and said ahead
of time it was such a skillful move to
come out and say they're going to arrest
me next week because if he doesn't get
arrested his base is like cool that
sounds good if he gets arrested they're
enraged they can't believe that this
happened to him and uh the element of
surprise that we've talked about a
little bit of the perp walk photo that I
think a lot of left-leaning journalists
would have really liked to have
published it's gone right it doesn't
have the same meaning and so really
Trump has come out as the winner in this
this scenario
to the detriment of the Democrats like
they they completely miscalculated how
he would handle the situation I wonder
if it's that Alvin Bragg is this
low-level nobody you know it's like
imagine you're the CEO of this big
company and you're about to do a big
merger deal or some big buyout and then
the janitor throws a water balloon at
the other company's president you're
like what are you doing you're gonna oh
what is this like so brag is this nobody
and he's like no I want to be famous so
I'm going to indict Trump and the
Democratic Leadership is like what is
this guy doing he is making Trump's base
fervent he is like riling them all up
filling his War chest and then I wonder
if he got a phone call and they were
like you need to stop see I wonder if it
absolutely happened that way yeah well I
also wonder if the New York AG Leticia
James initially was like we've got to
move forward we've been investigating
Trump for like three years at this point
you know someone has to bring charges
against him Alvin you do it and then it
all backfired she's like stop
immediately you're making us all look
bad like he's kind of being thrown to
the Wolves too and would hate to be him
right they would do that I I no probably
not this is just my crazy conspiracy
theory side it's about Justice also
yesterday we we talked about it and
Michael Cohen is apparently the one that
paid Stormy Daniels 125 Grand Trump is
from the evidence I saw yesterday there
was no evidence of trump paying or
anything so maybe there is evidence of
that that I haven't seen no there's yes
there's no evidence and what they're
doing is that Cohen paid the money and
then in the legal bills that Trump paid
is a comparable amount of money they're
like aha that proves it and it's like no
it just proves that Cohen lied and he
went to jail for it because he's a liar
that's what he does there were some
great AI per block photos of trump which
make him look badass I'll be honest
because he's like screaming and fighting
with the cops and like getting have you
seen those did you guys yeah I did but
did you see the AI photos of Obama fauci
Biden being arrested Hillary Clinton
those I got a weird feeling inside when
I saw those photos
yeah it's like a warm fuzzy feeling
uh-oh that's the AI being like plug in
the world that you want is just to click
away no the one fuzzy feeling was like
you know could there exist a world where
it's like there's a picture of Obama and
he's the cops are grabbing him and
pulling him and he's like fighting and
I'm like wow it makes me so sad and at
the same time like
seen that photo knowing it's not real
it's kind of a weird warm fuzzy sadness
because you know like Obama should be in
jail he should be arrested and
criminally charged and it's never going
to happen I don't think he should what
because he was killed the kid dude but
he was president when he died I don't
care what he said okay yeah what
technically yeah would you feel that way
if you hit someone like well drunk
driving while the president
what if Obama walked out to Fifth Avenue
and just shot a kid in the face and then
it would be like well he's a president
he can do it because he's the president
like if no no murder would be a
different thing but ordering a drone
strike that collaterally kills an
American kid collaterally no no no no no
no targeted him
what did the draft actually no you're
right I think he targeted a war criminal
son because he wanted to kill his family
what where was the country which country
was the Drone strike uh in I think it
was in it was in the Middle East uh I
mean this was it Yemen Yemen have we
ever been at war with Yemen well the
Saudis are at war with Yemen have we
ever been at War One
have we the United States declared war
on Yemen not that I know of no okay and
what was the Target in Yemen
I don't know a civilian restaurant so
there is no circumstance where Obama is
innocent in this I don't I mean when
you're the president and you're in
control of the military and you have a
war enemy and you want to kill his
family members we are not at war with
Yemen yemeni civilians I agree we
haven't been a war since World War II
yes but we're not like you can make the
argument that well you know in Iraq and
Syria there's a war going on with an
eight there's an aumf the Congress
authorized these military military force
Obama was like or uh what's this uh
country we're gonna be blown up it's
Yemen Sir with them no uh what's our
Target it's a civilian restaurant blow
them up get it done like what there's
literally no circumstance where that not
as a there's that is not a capital
offense I I I I'm sorry that's worse if
Barack Obama walked out in the street
with a gun and shot a kid that is not
nearly as bad as ordering a drone strike
on a civilian restaurant using the might
of the American Military a multi-million
how much is a Hellfire missile cost to
blow up 600 Grand or something more more
Millions to blow up a bunch of civilians
and an American citizen that would be
like Obama getting a a group of military
a group of soldiers and ordering them to
open fire on a little league baseball
game or something what about dropping
Napalm on villages in Vietnam all of
that is bad dude but you don't imprison
the guy the commander no no listen we
everything that happened in Vietnam was
complete BS and yes but the commander is
not the president okay so there is there
is an issue of the banality of Evil And
if someone is ordered to drop Nepal on
civilians yeah I'm gonna be in favor of
them going to prison you do not get to
be like but my boss told me to do it and
if Barack Obama is like I'm gonna rubber
stamp blown up civilians I'm gonna be
like well then you could go to jail so
if they want to come out and complain
about Donald Trump and Stormy Daniels my
response is this WOW Donald Trump
committed this crime you think oh okay
we're gonna have to arrest him I think
he should get the maximum for this
misdemeanor yeah 11 months and 30 days
Donald Trump no no no don't Matt don't
give me that look he has to go and then
afterwards we'll send Obama Obama to
prison for life for the execution and
murder of children but what about like
you're letting a lot of politicians off
the hook because I kind of I'm just
starting their school of thought that
all politicians are criminals and
particularly all Chief Executives have
committed war crimes against humanity so
while we're arresting people and
imprisoning them let's let's grow the
list let's not shrink it who do you want
to add I we were talking about before
don't I want to ask but we were talking
about before the show and I mentioned
this and you were like I'll take that
compromise yeah like I I like Trump but
I will gladly accept him getting a few
months on a misdemeanor charge if it
means Obama gets life in prison for for
the things that he did there's there's
no excuse there's no but he was in
charge of the military dude if I ask
someone to hold my weapons for me you
know like I'm gonna put you in charge of
of the weapons in this house use it
responsibly and it goes okay and then he
grabs and starts shooting a kid with it
I'd be like okay you're going to jail
like we're gonna we're gonna stop you
and lock you up we did not entrust you
with our military Arsenal so you could
go and blow up civilians in a country we
are not at war with
end of story it was the the son of a
terrorist so it was like a war tech it
was like a war attack it happened to be
in Yemen but that's where the kid was
like if the kid went to Jersey you know
we'll look out oh okay so you're saying
that you're probably gonna say that guy
because he's the child and a minor child
of a terror I don't like War but I mean
that's how War functions I think what he
said no no it no like dude you kill the
enemy's family I mean that's attack what
he's saying is that Barack Obama got the
Nobel Peace Prize so stop it yes like
what about the firebombing of Dresden in
Germany was that should they have been
executed should Isaac who was it the
President Truman was he why are you
conflating active warfare with
declarations and and the world
involvement with a country is not at war
with us but Obama wanted to send a
message so he executed Amer an American
citizen by blowing up a civilian
restaurant like
there's there's no comparison what's the
war on terror okay so imagine if Barack
Obama got mad at the Mexican drug
cartels so him and his buddies got a
bunch of fully automatic rifles went to
the home of a bunch of Hispanic children
who are who are uh friends with or had
grown up with these cartel members and
started shooting a bunch of kids well
sorry that's that's the War on Drugs
Obama had no choice but start shooting
kids in the face if American government
went to war with the cartels you better
believe family members will start dying
in the in the United States you are you
are making the argument that we should
not criminally prosecute Obama because
the extrajudicial assassination of an
American citizen in a country we're not
at war with is Justified because that
was the son of someone we were targeting
in a different country
I I think if you start Prosecuting
presidents for war crimes after every
every president would go to prison and
then yes and they wouldn't be able to do
their job it's like telling a cop they
can't get rough with their with the guy
they're arresting it's at some point
you've got to let the president do war
no no I mean it's not commander-in-chief
of the military what do you you just
want to end just let other people win
the war I mean what do you so I don't
know what Abdul Rahman Allah was doing
that was helping these terrorists win
any kind of War other than drinking
coffee and having to have been related
to a guy no man they sent a message to
the dad oh okay right right yes that's
right so yeah it's called a war crime
look in war there there is a reason why
we have I I think war crimes are a silly
concept right because it's like if
you're at War you're trying to win but
there is a difference between tactics
and retribution you know so like if we
were to if if the United States was like
we're gonna stop Isis by any means
necessary and then they did a whole
bunch of really messed up stuff like
napalming cities and stuff I would be
mad about that I'd be like dude we need
to stop Isis but you know doing this is
is too far but I understand it's
military we're talking about Obama
dropping bombs
on civilians who we are not at war with
all that's going to do is make the war
worse like if people are at war with us
and then you send in troops to a
neighboring country and start executing
kids you are going to make war more war
and generate more enemies Barack Obama
should be in prison
I'm thinking about the Fallujah the
white phosphorus attack on Fallujah in
2003 where they they use it as an
illuminate because they were like yeah
we're going to light up the sky so we
can see our targets but really it melts
human skin so they just drop white
phosphorus all in the city of Fallujah
and just melted all these civilian skin
that was George Bush Jr oh yeah George
George Bush can go to prison he's on my
list so yes I don't know the amount of
Clinton's bombings in Bosnia I know the
clintons Bro the clintons are on our
list too and then Trump I think I think
we'll go all the way with this you keep
racking up the names giving the Drone
bombing campaign to his generals is that
not treason Donald Trump
is imperfect however he was pulling
troops out of the Middle East he had no
new Wars he was trying to get our troops
out of Syria I look at what Trump was
doing as trying to stop these things
granted he inherited a lot of it from
Obama from George W bush and that's bad
however I Look to who started it and who
was trying to stop it
Donald Trump was trying to stop it
Barack Obama was escalating it George W
Bush started it I'm not going to hold
that against Trump granted there are
some things I think Trump did that were
bad that we need accountability for I
don't know if it goes as far as saying
like Donald Trump pulled our troops was
pulling troops out of the Middle East so
he increased drone strikes to to uh to
maintain control the territory I'm like
I don't blame him for that I blame Obama
for that not that I like it or anything
but Obama was like blown up kids now
granted there is the story of the
Commando raid in Yemen which resulted in
the death of an eight-year-old American
Girl that if proven to be Trump's orders
then I believe Trump deserves prison for
that as well however that story is still
a bit of conjecture and we don't know
when it comes to abdurman al-alaki this
is reported far and wide by like every
major media news source and the family
and you know so you take it for what it
is
all that really matters is you know what
indict them all indictable if they want
to engage in this kind of foreign policy
but I but I gotta say man
you know I've had I've had a lot of
Libertarians and I don't know how you
feel about tell me that Trump is the
lesser of two evils and I disagree he
crossed the DMZ in North Korea with no
security detail he helped negotiate the
Abraham Accords a lot of that was Jared
Kushner I like that he was trying to get
our trips out of Syria very good he
crushed Isis very very good he set a
deadline for getting out of Afghanistan
I'm like yo this guy's doing good stuff
I will take what I can get
Barack Obama was escalating it George W
bush is starting it the clintons were
engaged in all of it it goes all the way
back I'll take what I can get with Trump
I don't know what your thoughts are yeah
I mean the question the Practical
question is I think the war on terror
has been a disaster and I'm channeling
my inner Ron Paul here and say we never
should have done it and we've made
things far worse and we've killed a lot
of Innocents and created lots of chaos
but the Practical question for the next
president if it's Trump or somebody else
is how do you extract us from all of
this without starting new Wars and and I
I'm willing to grant that that's a messy
process and I I would give uh Trump
credit on all of those things for mostly
moving in the right direction not always
but but mostly moving in the right
direction and you know he didn't get us
out of Afghanistan and I wish he would
have succeeded that because the way
Biden did it was was a tragic show
or I don't know if we're allowed to say
show oh yeah after 15 seconds yeah
yeah I I I almost feel like they
intentionally sabotaged Afghanistan to
guarantee their ability to reinvade
later if they want to it sure looks like
that I had there's a congressman Warren
Davidson who's been like a real hero
saying we got to get our guys out no
matter what and I asked him is this just
gross incompetence the way we got out of
Afghanistan or was it purposeful
and and he in a very political way said
I don't see how it can't have been
purposeful so that the lesson is don't
ever get out of anything ever again
because it it doesn't work and you have
to wonder why they would abandon Bagram
Air Force base without notifying
security forces in the country why they
cut all air air support Logistics
there's no way it wasn't attention why
they left all that equipment and didn't
decommission it with Nano thermite like
they didn't melt the machines before
they just left they just signed and and
they were purposely blocking private
efforts they had they had Transportation
they had people and all the state
department had to say was do it and they
blocked it Lincoln testified today that
there are still like over 100 175
Americans still there like they left
people behind on purpose like there's no
way that this wasn't intentional thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time